doit amener vianney à la rencontre du
peuple afar en ethiopie merci bon c'est
bon tu peux la géographie l'afrique quoi
la corne de l'afrique d'accord la
capitale c'est vrai addis abeba bravo en
capital au capital de supor
ouais ouais c'est vrai oui bah oui
demandé - capitale argentine argentine
buenos aires non avec l'accent de votre
allié australie australie finlandais
rabbe héros on voit à malley mal alors
balles faciles ouais il va l'être ça va
l'être
ouais la ville est l'avion les chéris
gros carton pour l'émission de 5,6
millions d'électeurs et comme à chaque
fois l'émission coupon ce temps là me
rappelle le canada a un petit bruit pas
mieux mais bon on va l'appeler rappel du
marocain matin au travail du maroc qui
brille tant d'années de l'endroit vers
lequel il se dirige sauf que le bruit
n'est pas hyper rassurant puisque vous
savez que les invités ne savent pas où
ils vont évoluer ouais c'est fou hein
c'est comme quand on signe ici c'est je
pense une des régions les plus hostiles
de la planète avec des conditions
extrêmes on est dans une région
désertique une région volcanique
on est à 150 mètres en dessous du niveau
de la mer et les températures moyennes
sont entre 40 et 52 années mais que je
vois les rallonges voilà il n'est pas au
bout donc ouais
tu pars
en ethiopie
c'est un rêve d'y aller il ya personne
dans l'avion c'est normal à business
c'est pour ça qu'on est en business à
personne ce jour là il y avait deux
personnes
ah oui merci si vous étiez en émissions
vont quoi qui bat vous vous étiez
démissionner pour l'équipe pour ça qu'il
est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà remplir les avions avec qui tu va
pas tarder à retourner dans son camion
pas à sa taille et bien cha cha va
retrouver ton billboard capable est ce
que pour vous c'était le meilleur
un des meilleurs débits oui très
franchement je suis pas fan de
l'émission mais là rien à dire
raphaël de casablanca est parfait dans
l'empathie vianès et je dirais le client
idéal baqim il est vrai bienveillant
compréhensif voit la vraie intelligent
c'était très bien franchement j'ai été
émue alors non je suis pas daccord
richie moi j'ai un problème avec raphaël
de casablanca qui le nouvel animateur
avant cette émission c'était une
émission animée par faudrait l'aise avec
un invité
lassé vianney qui fait l'émission tout
seul c'est lui qui fait les séquences il
kim et de l'émotion il ne regarde assez
des mots sales c'est vrai que ça manque
d'un animateur qui tient émissions comme
frédéric lemoine je pense que tu ne vois
pas tout le travail de casablanca parce
que justement toute sa force c'est
d'être en retrait et de permettre à
vianney entre deux poses de pause et de
se mettre en valeur c'est lui la vedette
c'est fait c'est lui c'est 1000 cc
l'invité en question qu on a envie de
voir la surprise l'émotion les
interrogations casablanca lui il est ni
surpris ni et mun il y connaît déjà
donc c'est ouais c'était toute sa force
et moi je trouve que bravo à frédéric
lopez ce qu'il a trouvé un très bon il
faut de temps mais ce qui reste est
produit
oui moi je pense que ça les arrange bien
frédéric lopez parce qu'il reste il ya
sûrement pas bien changé dans le
générique et je pense que c'est très dur
de passer derrière avec la presse qu'il
avait une grosse personnalité et moi
quand je le vois rafale casablanca si on
avait coupé votre phrase avant un
week-end très généreux savez quoi c'est
très dur de passer derrière fenech
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas été coupée pour
moi le mec qui arrive il paraît que
c'est pas facile et quand ils en plateau
notamment quand tu y es à la fille avec
ses églantine eméyé à la beaucoup plus
de personnalité quelques lui j'ai
l'impression prix va servir des jus de
fruits qu'il est là pour servir des
tarifs fournisseurs quand il est en
immersion c'est l'état farine tropicana
c'est vrai mais quand il est en plein
temps c'est pas mal mais en immersion
c'est pas mal d'emplois et il plaît ce
qu'on appelle la ménagère la responsable
des achats mais moi je suis une ménagère
chez nos jeunes en galère je vous le dis
personne ne s'aperçoit de vote auraient
demandé son nom
moi je trouve des cas mais c'est nous
qui la grèce s'est passé c'est ça qui
est super intéressant c'est que c'est
totalement effacés oui c'est bien n'est
vraiment qui a fait l'audience situe la
seriat du programme n'a mis que sur
l'émotion sur l'authenticité sur la
sincérité
il a été extradé année dont call en
ethiopie à la rencontre du peuple afar
qui vit à 150 mètres au dessous du
niveau de la mer ce soit sur une femme
hyperactive voilà oui oui un peu comme
moi elle est parcourue de volcans dans
des conditions climatiques éprouvantes
et les températures autour parfois de 50
degrés elle vous pourriez pas vous
habiller là bas l'arrivée de vianney et
de raphaël de djerba là bas comme ici il
n'y a que mes cousines est et leurs
enfants
david est ce que c'est ton frère non
c'est mohamed mon meilleur ami
escape incroyable c'est que c'est qu'ils
sont si peu nombreux et circuler parce
que je veux dire peuvent compter là
vraiment que sur eux mêmes
[Musique]
il ya combien de familles qui vivent ici
une seule
il n'y a que des membres de ma famille y
a qu une seule famille 1 oui oui je suis
pas du tout d'accord avec guillaume
genton comme d'habitude avant tu disais
je vois rendez vous en terre inconnue
avec frédéric lopez ou non bannon
tunisie je vais voir maintenant je vais
voir cette émission avec un dicton dit
avec christina reali avec la grandeur
avec mais non
jane l'animateur moi je trouve qu'il est
extraordinaire parce que justement il
accouche de l'âme
tu vas y avait un quota à la salle de la
halle actuellement voilà d'un maillot du
chanteur populaire yannick est juste
évidemment exceptionnelle qui est
solaire qui est charismatique apporte
énormément au programme mais je trouve
que justement il a sa place et les
formidables pour le programmer mais non
il y avait une double émotion
moi j'aimais bien justement voir
l'artiste pleurer et frédéric lopez sont
à l'heure à la fin casablanca oui mais
c'est pour les départements on retient
moins bas d'ailleurs là moi ma cg pas
revenus tandis qu'avec frédéric lopez
était parfois je préférais l'animateur
que parfois certains participants et
bonbons casting à vialer satine nombre
d'avions bon qu'à sa part eric abidal
pop voilà messine oui il s'est un petit
peu compliqué que se tient sur la grosse
personnalité connue mais voilà et c'est
vrai que ça a joué aussi je pense dans
les chiffres mais est ce que vous vous
rendez compte qu'avant ça faisait plus
d'humidité
c'est vrai mais voilà et mais c'est vrai
que voyez thomas puisqu'ils qui l'a
battu voilà parce que lui là ils l'ont à
des drôles dans l'espace
vous savez juste une chose à la fin
vianney voulait laisser ses vêtements
voulait laisser ses chaussures etc à la
famille en question la production de lui
a interdit tout en expliquant que
c'était pas il fallait pas les dénaturer
il fallait pas et en revanche ils ont
ils leur ont donné un dromadaire une
fiole de kilos de sucre et de farine en
disant ça va leur servir réellement
plutôt que tes chaussures août et voilà
et donc c'est intéressant aussi de voir
que c'est pas que doc déjà lui voulait
dans une cabine à uv le chantier
il avait offert sa roue ça et c'est
intéressant parce que la production lui
a donné toute la tenue qu'il avait là ça
vaut le coup d'y aller moi je veux bien
mais s'il a écrit une très jolie chanson
qui date des années la passion elle a
écrit par jean-jacques goldman
[Rires]
il me raconte eliane et qu'il est parti
le 1er janvier tournée et quand il est
revenu l'après-midi même il n'a pas eu
le temps du tout de faire son deuil si
j'ose dire ce que l'après midi même il
enchaînait the voice non tant qu'il est
passé du tout nu rien compris un bruit
assez incroyable il a tourné une fière
ton staff incroyable ans quand il est
revenu il reste quand même temps la date
de ce jour c'est beaucoup oui est ce qui
a le plus choqué je crois c'est que
chaque homme peut avoir deux trois
justement va en parler de la polygamie
regarder sans labaste une tradition et
le choc des cultures était assez
intéressant à voir hier pour voir ça pas
besoin d'aller jusqu'à là bas pour aller
directement chez guillaume genton en
même temps tu sais que nous on choisit
une femme dans notre vie pourquoi vous
ne vous mariez pas avec plusieurs femmes
nous on peut avoir deux ou trois
absolument si on en a les moyens
ces quads et autres soumah naby soumah
c'est le mariage avec une cousine
s'il ya plusieurs filles célibataires et
tu peux avoir plusieurs femmes
je pense que s'il ya une chose à retenir
vraiment c'est que les vérités
culturelle elle n'existe pas nos visions
ne regarde que nous et qu'on peut être
différent et qu'on détient pas plus la
vérité que que ces gens viennent et
c'est vrai que moi j'ai adoré ce peuple
envie d'y aller oui on a envie d'y aller
si on vous le propose des mots si on
vous le proposez vous feriez sur le roi
d'intégrer le parent de deux parties
[Applaudissements]
grand plaisir c'est sa doublure il
apparaît souriant mais ça c'est trop
long mais oui si j'aime beaucoup appel
de casablanca
je le connais pas mm bien pour lui je
pense que pour sa santé bien sûr mais on
sentait les jeunes beaucoup de personnes
son camion son téléphone
ah non vous êtes coquet mais là il n'y a
pas une source de commissionner pour
aller chier dans les fougères à huy non
moi ce que j'ai trouvé très fort chez
viennent et que justement en fait ils
s'intéressaient il était pas nier le il
posait des vraies questions et avec son
bagage culturel d'occidental il a posé
des questions ils sont embêtés y avait
du coup un choc de civilisations et les
cultures
il savait que c'était très intéressant
annoncé à laurent blanc la polygamie n'a
pas été le seul sujet qui a étonné n'y a
ni il ya une autre tradition quidam en
écoute surprise c'est le don d'enfants
oui c'est à dire que pour les peuples
des afars chaque premier enfant ici même
nom et thomas d'abandonner et à marcel
parent on sait bien que quand l'enfant
naît la mer le donne à sa mère oui oui
mais la fesci sa mère devient mère et le
père devient grand père et un frère de
sa mère
mais la maman reste avec les critiques
je n'ai jamais vu ça
personne n'a des cheveux qui poussent
sur les bras comme sur la tête
je raconte aux autres que j'ai vu des
points comme ça sur les bras d'un homme
personne ne croira rafale gsm et bien
que c'était pas des noirs dîner ma
première femme à donner notre fils aîné
habiba ma mère est ma seconde femme à
donner notre premier enfant à sa mère à
l abîmer mon fils et mon frère car il va
suivre non explique moi là c'est
beaucoup pour moi c'est pourtant ça
parce que j'y reviens est-ce qu'on se
relever chez nous c'est les gens perdus
qui chante comme ça aujourd'hui
d'intégrer j'aime pas rendez moi tu as
connu j'ai envie d'intégrer ce pub je
suis pas trop pour lui de nombreux
artistes et très intrigué j'espère
qu'ils vont pas mettre tous les
intrigues et la guitare ah oui la
guitare ça les avait jamais vus de
guitare de leur vie et dès que les sons
sont partis les premiers comme ça ils
ont été très émus et la chanter pour eux
c'était magnifique village j'ai vu j'ai
vu des missions je sais je sais les
missions bolliger la téloche
oui c'est que c'était une arme parce que
c'est un peuple guerrier qui a des armes
parce qu'ils sont souvent en guerre
et puis finalement ils ont découvert le
sang et c'est vrai que la chanson que
vianney a composé pour eux est
magnifique
ces succès un très très bien marquer
avec vous c'est pour qu'elles viennent
lancer l'émission
non non non non c'est ça s'est passé à
au moment où j étais effectivement mais
bon faut pas donner votre avis comment
alors pas du tout c'était au magazine
mais par contre quel sacré abcès les
records d'audience qu'a pu faire cette
émission vous parliez de 8 millions on
est monté je crois jusqu'à 9 millions 1
est l'un des plus grands records
d'audience sur france télévisions mais
même hier quand vous regardez les cibles
c'est juste incroyable sacré incroyable
ça a cartonné
mais est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un
des meilleurs rendez-vous inter en terre
inconnue à 37 ans je suis complètement
d'accord avec vous